.
>> I LOVED IT.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE NOT ONLY ON THE
VERGE OF LOSING THE MIDTERMS,
THEY COULD BE ON THE VERGE OF
LOSING THE MEDIA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN TRYING TO PAINT
THE PICTURE OF A PERFECT
ECONOMY, BUT THE VOTERS AND YOU
AND THE MEDIA SAY OTHERWISE.
OUR FOX NEWS ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT
78% THINK THE STATE OF THE
ECONOMY IS NOT SO GOOD OR POOR.
AND THREE MAJOR LIBERAL OUTLETS
ARE GETTING TOUGH ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S ROSY DEPICTIONS OF A
STRONG ECONOMY.
GET THIS.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS A
FACT CHECKER, AWARDED THE
PRESIDENT, A BOTTOM LINELESS
PINOCCHIO.
DANA, IS TIMING EVERYTHING IN
THIS OR HAS IT BECOME TOO MUCH?
>> I THINK IT GOT TO BE TOO
MUCH.
IF YOU THINK IT'S BAD TODAY,
WAIT UNTIL TOMORROW, BECAUSE
THAT'S WHEN THE MEDIA IS GOING
TO START SAYING THEY SHOULD HAVE
DONE THIS, THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE
THAT, START NITPICKING THEM.
ONE OF THE THINGS I REMEMBER
FROM BEING IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
WHEN WE HAD THE MAJORITY, UP
UNTIL 2006, WHEN THAT FLIPPED,
THE MEDIA'S ATTENTION
IMMEDIATELY TURNED TO CAPITOL
HILL.
WE WERE ON THE BACK FOOT FOR A
LOT OF THAT.
THAT WILL START HAPPENING.
ALSO THE MEDIA TOMORROW WILL
START ASKING IF PRESIDENT BIDEN
SHOULD RUN AGAIN.
I THINK THE ANSWER IS GOING TO
BE NO.
>> THEY PICKED UP THINGS, FOR
EXAMPLE, HE SAYS GRASS IS $3.39.
NO.
IT'S $3.72.
WHY DO THEY CARE NOW, JESSE?
>> WELL, I THINK THEY'RE TRYING
TO SEE CYA, BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
I'M GOING TO STEAL THE JUDGE'S
LINE FROM THE LAST BLOCK, WHERE
HAVE YOU BEEN?
YOU CAN'T ALL OF A SUDDEN THROW
PINOCCHIOS AT THEM ON THE 7th
OF NOVEMBER?
WHERE WERE THE PINOCCHIOS LAST
YEAR.
>> OR ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
JUDGE, ARE YOU SURPRISED BY THE
TIMING, THAT EVERYONE SEEMS TO
BE ON THE SAME PAGE ON THE LEFT?
>> NO.
THE TRUTH IS THE MEDIA
UNDERSTANDS WHAT'S COMING DOWN
THE PIKE.
COMES THE COMING DOWN THE PIKE
IS BECAUSE THE MEDIA, THE LEFT,
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ALL BEEN IN
CAHOOTS.
THEY WANT TO TAKE THEMSELVES OUT
OF THAT EQUATION AND SAY, OH,
NO, WE'VE BEEN CRITICIZING HIM
TOO.
THE TRUTH IS THE MEDIA IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE DEMOCRATIC
LIES THEY'VE BEEN SPEWING FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
IF YOU ASK JOE BIDEN, HE SAYS
THE ECONOMY IS BETTER THAN EVER.
>> RIGHT.
DOES THIS REMIND YOU, HAROLD, OF
CLINTON, WHEN HE GOT PLASTERED
IN HIS MIDTERM, OR OBAMA, WHEN
HE GOT SHELLACKED?
>> IT DOES.
WE HAVE TO CORRECT SOME THINGS.
THERE WAS A BIG VERBAL FISTFIGHT
WITH CNN A YEAR AGO, SAYING WE
COVERED IT ON THE SHOW, I DON'T
THINK WE COVERED IT FAIRLY.
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO BE MORE
CANDID ABOUT WHAT'S WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT WORKING.
I HOPE WILL ALSO HAPPEN, THE FAR
LEFT IN MY PARTY, THEIR
INTENTIONS ARE GOOD IN WANTING
TO HELP THE COUNTRY, BUT THEIR
PLAN AND IMPLEMENTATION HAVE NOT
BEEN.
DEMOCRATS WILL HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION.
IF TONIGHT GOES, LIKE WE THINK
IT MAY GO, DO YOU WANT TO WIN
ELECTRICS AND HELP GOVERN THE
COUNTRY THAT ADVANCES OUR
STRATEGIC OBJECTIVES OR SIDE
WITH A GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO MAY
HAVE GOOD INTENTION BUT WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE WHEN IT COMES TO
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING A
PLAN?
THAT'S WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
ASSESS THIS EVENING.
REPUBLICANS ARE INTERESTED IN
PROBLEM-SOLVING.
I HOPE THERE'S DEMOCRATS THAT
WANT TO JOIN THEM.
>> IF THEY START TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHING JOE BIDEN --
>> THAT WOULD BE A TERRIBLE
THING.
>> THAT'